first question here 3z squared minus 2z
plus 2 equals 0 looking for some
solutions
uh these are the solutions i think we
found yeah
uh 1 plus or minus i root 5 on
3. do i have some agreement yeah i'm
getting nods okay
so just real quick i think it'll be my
next one here
um this is me just flat using the
quadratic formula
on this guy right um a minor difference
that you'll see like very minor right at
the end there i've left mine in
rectangular form
this is like pretty close to rectangular
form isn't it but we want to separate
out the real part
and the imaginary part that's often very
useful for what our next step
might be i'm actually going to hit pause
on question uh one two whatever it's
called this other one here
you'll see why a bit later on we'll
revisit it um this last one here so
you've got two solutions coming out of
this uh quadratic with complex
coefficients
those complex coefficients make a
straightforward use of the quadratic
formula
teeny bit messier so you may have done
that and you would have arrived at the
same answer but
this is how my working looks
it's how it looks okay completing the
square
you'll arrive at have we got here let's
see negative 2
minus 2 minus 2i looks good to me right
um the advantage is you don't have to
deal with
long awkward square root signs and the
enormous fraction that is at the heart
of the quadratic formula
but all of the arithmetic ends up being
the same so whichever you feel
um best with that's okay with me are you
happy with that
thumbs up please rule that off and then
the heading i would like you to make is
roots of unity
now let me explain uh what this means
before we
dive right in last time we were having a
look at
solving equations that end up with
complex solutions
like these right now one of the reasons
for that was so that we could move from
square roots of complex numbers into
general roots of complex numbers not
just square roots but maybe like cube
roots
fourth roots fifth whatever number we're
going to have a look at nth roots all of
this week
but in order to make things like sort of
ease us into this we're going to look at
the nth roots of a particular complex
number called
unity now this number is really
important it's so important it doesn't
just have
a fancy name like unity it's got another
fancy name it's called the
multiplicative you can write this down
because it's kind of
i mean it's not within the scope of the
course but it's still interesting anyway
it's called the multiplicative identity
you know something's a big deal when
it's got a big fancy name like that
what is this special hallowed number and
the answer is
it's one you're like oh really that was
it okay of course it is one because
that's why it's unity like unit a single
object um and of course it's called the
multiplicative identity multiplicative
identity because
when you multiply something by one the
answer is
identical doesn't change right 3 times 1
is 3 i times 1 is
i doesn't change the number okay now you
might think
why is it so special like one seems like
a very basic number why do we get all
these special names
for starters this is not the only number
that we give a special name to
right like this guy this guy also has a
special
name especially when you think about
where it is on the complex plane what do
we normally call this number
we call the origins oh special by the
way it has another name like this as
well it's called the
not the multiplicative identity it's
called the additive
identity because when you add it to
things it doesn't change identical right
so we want to focus on this number for
two reasons number one
it's a simple number so it's easy to
deal with even though we're in complex
numbers okay so
we're going to be able to pull out some
algebraic and some
other tricks that were useful to us that
we can't do with all the rest of the
numbers that's reason number one
reason number two the roots of unity
actually have some really delicious
properties which we'll get to once you
find out what they are okay so
let's start with the first one that we
already don't know which is we've looked
at the square roots
of unity you could work out what they
are by the way what are
the two numbers the two complex numbers
that if you multiply them by themselves
will give you one
square roots think i know it's the end
of a long day and you might not have
much sleep but you can tell me this what
are the two numbers give me at least one
of them
i think this is just positive one right
so
i'll give you i'll give you one for free
one
is one of the square roots of one
because one times one
is one what's the other one it's
negative one isn't it right now we
usually would exclude negative one
because we
say this principle square root is just
is just 1 but actually we've been sort
of exploring that negative 1 times
negative 1 still gives you this
so it is also one of the square roots of
unity the next one
is the cube roots of unity
so how do we work out what these cube
roots are
now the first question i'm going to ask
you is if there are two square roots of
every
complex number out there how many cubers
do you expect there to be
this should be three right like that's
the cubing raised to the third power
okay so how do we find these three um
you already know about one of them
it's one okay or what are the other two
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to pull out the same kind of
trick we looked at before you don't have
to write this down but
do you remember when we were finding
a square root of a number we would say
well there's some number if you square
it
that will give you whatever complex
number you started with right well i'm
going to pull the same trick out but
instead of squaring i'm going to
q okay let's write this down so i'm
going to use a
a new greek letter here new
this is not a w it's an omega or a
lowercase omega i should say
this is the um this is the uppercase
omega it's friends of
uh fans of greenland who know this omega
cubed
right if it's if this omega is the cube
root of unity then when i cube it i
should end up with
one that that's unity isn't it okay and
how do i solve
this equation well as i mentioned before
because this is a simple number
i can do some things with it that i
can't do with
other kinds of numbers right i can do
some sort of
algebraic um gymnastics here okay now
you guys are used to factorizing things
like the sum and difference of squares
we know how to do that right
we can do difference of squares through
normal numbers we can do sum of squares
using
the imaginary unit this is not the sum
of difference of squares it's the sum of
difference of
cubes but thankfully for us there is
actually a result
that is a nice factorization of this it
used to be part of the course it's no
longer but some of you might have
encountered before does anyone know
what the factorization is morgan so your
father is w
minus one uh omega minus one that's okay
i knew what you meant
and then and then omega plus
omega plus yeah and then omega
and then plus one okay so this this
result right here
is called the difference of cubes here's
two cubes you're taking the difference
and this is the factorization as i
pointed out it's not in the course
anymore so don't stress out if you've
never seen this before
but just for the rest of you who are
like this is new let's just content
ourselves this is not just black magic
it actually works
let's expand it out it's not hard right
i'm going to multiply everything by
omega and then i'm going to multiply
everything by minus 1. watch it just
kind of falls out right
here's me multiplying by omega
and then here's me multiplying by minus
1 but i'm just going to write it down
here
are you okay with that that's the six
terms you get you're like cancel cancel
cancel cancel
ta-da there's my difference of cubes
okay so it does work you can contain
yourself for that
now at this point we're trying to solve
for omega we already knew one of the
solutions here it is omega equals
1. we already knew this but then you've
got this other
factor this can equal zero we've dealt
with that
but if this equals zero these should be
our other mystery
cube roots right so i need to solve this
guy
omega squared plus omega plus 1
equals 0. if i can solve this i'll have
my other two solutions now thankfully
for you you
solve this exact equation quite recently
like
all of 15 minutes ago okay they're right
here
these are the other solutions if you
didn't know this of course
if you didn't have a teacher who gave it
to you as a starter question you'd have
to go through the process
of solving this using the quadratic
formula okay but these would be the
answers you get
so let's just quickly jot that down
negative half i'm actually going to
separate these out as the two separate
numbers okay
i've got the negative case so minus root
3
onto i and then i've got the positive
case i've still got
negative a half out the front but now
it's plus
root 3 on to i
this is our result we've got cube roots
we have three numbers here's one of them
here is a second one and here is a
third one now what we're going to do is
go in two directions from here i
mentioned before that these cube roots
have or actually all the roots
of unity have interesting properties to
them to try and sort of bring that out
what i'd like you to do is to
plot on an argan diagram all three of
these complex numbers that's the first
thing i'm going to ask you to do
and then secondly we're going to come up
with these same results but we're going
to use
a few of the other tools in our toolbox
to get there and see if we can gain some
insights from that
so whilst i arrange myself on the board
go ahead draw yourself an arguing
diagram and find where one two
three of our cube roots should belong
okay off we go
what do we got here on our complex plane
um hopefully you have one
uh minus a half or negative a half minus
root 3 on 2i
and then its conjugate negative half
plus
root 3 onto i and there they are
positioned
what can you tell me about these
particular points on the complex plane
and you want to
jump out there's a lot of things to
observe anyone want to start us off
morgan's got some got a thought i will
hit pause on morgan because he's already
contributed some great thoughts today
um giu do you notice anything worth
pointing out
um between negative 4
to r three on two i
true one is actually equal to the length
of negative one over two minus root
three on two
i ah okay so there's some there's some
symmetry here
right we should expect this because
these two are conjugates so they're
the exact same distance from the real
axis
so the distances that i think jelly was
talking about
were these is that are these ones you're
talking about right these two
are in fact equal they're not just equal
to each other they're equal to something
else
where else are they equal to each other
yeah there's a
there's a vertical between these two
conjugates right um in fact
this sure looks like an equilateral
triangle now i should point out
it looks equilateral i don't know if
your diagram is good enough to reason
that but we can actually
prove it before we do that are there any
other things like apartheid that looks
equal actual any other things that we
can observe
anything yes susie
okay yeah let me put the center on i'll
put a different color yes what about the
center
fantastic so um the distance from each
of our cube roots
to the origin so i could indicate it
like so
like so and like so
um those distances we have a name for
this by the way distance to the origin
starts with now this is the modulus okay
so the modulus of each of these cube
roots
is equal and since i actually know the
length of this what is the length of
this by the way
the horizontal one that's one because
that's where you are that these are all
one
as well right so they're all one unit
away
from the origin that shouldn't surprise
us that much because
when we multiply these things by
themselves successively we want to end
up on one right we want to end up on
unity
if they were any smaller then as you
multiply they'll
shrink and drink and treat and get close
to the origin right if there were any
further away
as you successively multiply you'll get
further away from the origin does that
make sense
yeah any other things that you have
morgan give us some more your argument
is rotating
like you rotate it okay okay you rotate
the argument the same so
when we go from one cube root to the
next
right you can see there is you know
rotation is part of
multiplication like complex arithmetic
and you can see this rotation around
around around because they all add up to
uh
two pi radians right because there's
three angles there what's the size of
each angle
two pi on three which of course you
could verify if for instance
you chose like one of these guys and
converted it into
polar form you'd be able to verify that
fact does that make sense
okay